Transcriber: Sude Akgündoğdu
Gözden geçirme: Figen Ergürbüz
Merhaba arkadaşlar.
Bildiğiniz üzere anılar hareket ederler.
Belki bugün sizinle paylaşacağım anılar,
sizlerin hikâyelerinizin başlangıcı olacak
belki de eriyip gidecek.
Bunu ancak başlayarak bilebileceğiz.
O zaman başlayalım diyorum.
Bunun ne olduğu hakkında bilgisi
olan var mı?
Bu şu an için çekilmiş insanlı
ilk fotoğraf yani günümüze kadar bulunmuş
ortaya çıkartılmış, 180 yıl önce çekilmiş,
ilk insanlı fotoğraf bu kare.
Ama benim bunlar dışında sizinle paylaşmak
istediğim başka şeyler var.
Şimdi, 14, 15, 16, 17, 18 yaşlarımı
hatırladığımda, tam bir karadelik aklıma
geliyor. Boşluk içinde boşluk hatırlıyorum
Devamlı evreni hissetmeye çalışıyorsunuz
ama hissedemiyorsunuz. Ne olduğunuzu
bilemiyorsunuz. "Ben kimim? Amacım ne?"
"Ne olacağım? Hangi mesleği seçeceğim?"
bu gibi boşluklarda oluyorsunuz.
Aslında karadelik evrenin en bilinemez
parçalarından bir tanesi, ergenlik gibi.
Ve karadelik inanılmaz derecede içine
her şeyi çekebilen bir oluşum.
Magnet gibi çekiyor tüm olumlulukları
ve olumsuzlukları. Işığı da çekiyor.
Ama ışığı yaymıyor. Bence ergenlik ve
olgunluk arasındaki en büyük farklardan
bir tanesi, her şeyi çekiyor ama şu an
için hiçbir şey yansıtmıyor.
Eğer bu karadeliğin içine, ergenlik
zamanında, öğrenilmiş çaresizlikleri
çekerseniz, kendinizden çok çok emin bir
şekilde babanıza güvenirseniz, 15-16-17-18
yaşlarında, nasıl olsa ne istersem okurum,
nasıl olsa babamın şirketinde çalışırım,
derseniz, eğer sizi ne olacağınızı
bilmeden, daha hangi mesleği seçeceğinizi
bilmeden, sizi öğrenilmiş çaresizlikle bir
arada bırakanlarla birlikte olursanız bu
karadelikten çıkamazsınız arkadaşlar.
15 yaşında bana deselerdi ki sen 15 yıl
sonra TEDx konuşmasında oyun yapımcısı
olarak sahneye çıkacaksın.
Bir köyde dijital inkübasyon merkezi
kuracaksın deselerdi asla inanamazdım
çünkü ne olduğunu bilemezdim. Şimdi
sizlerden de birer meslek seçmeniz
bekleniyor. Ama biliyorlar mı ki bu
meslekler daha oluşmadı.
Ve şu anki mesleklerin %60'ı da yaklaşık
bir 15 yıl sonra kaybolacak.
Yeni yeni meslekler ortaya çıkacak.
Peki siz nasıl yolunuzu bulacaksınız
bu karadeliğin içinde?
Şimdi, evet, bu güzel bir şey, anılara
tutunmak, anılarla yaşamak önemli bir şey.
Ancak anı yaşamak propagandasından daha
çok en önemli şey şu:
Geçmişi şimdiyle tasarlamak. Geçmişi
şimdi gelecek için tasarlamak.
O yüzden biraz önce gösterdiğim 180 yıl
öncesine götürmek istiyorum sizleri.
Sizce ilk fotoğrafı çekilen insan mı
önemlidir, yoksa ilk insanlı fotoğrafı
çeken insan mı önemlidir?
Bence ilk insanlı fotoğrafı çeken adam
çok daha önemlidir.
Buradaki Louis-Jacques-Mandé Daguerre
aynı zamanda bir kimyager.
Ve yapmak istediği şey bir anı gerçek
zamanda dondurmak.
Bunun için çalışmalara başlıyor uzun süre,
daha önce tiyatro deneyimleri oluyor,
tiyatroda 3D gerçekçiliği getiriyor,
ve şimdiki VR deneyimlerimizi yaşamamızı
sağlıyor. Ama ilk fotoğrafı ise çekmeye
başladığında, kendi geliştirdiği teknikle,
8 dakika pozlama gerekiyor. Ve oturduğu
binadan çektiğinde ise, bakın şurada
görmüş olduğunuz insan fotoğrafın içine
girebiliyor çünkü sadece 8 dakika boyunca
ayakkabısını orada boyatan ve orada duran
tek insan. Normalde burada birçok arabalar
geçiş yapıyor, insanlar yürüyor ama onlar
çıkmıyor. Düşünsenize şu an elinizde olan
ve devamlı selfie çektiğiniz, devamlı
anları paylaştığınız...
Arkadaşlar bu fotoğrafın sürati ve hızı
bu şekilde bizlere ulaşmaya çalışıyor.
Geçen hafta İsviçre'deydim. Bavulumda
birçok çikolata ve peynir getirdim.
Ama onun yanında harika bir de hikâye
getirdim. CERN'deydim Cenevre'de kurulan
Avrupa Nükleer Araştırma Enstitüsü'ndeydim
Orada çok güzel bir hikaye öğrendim.
Willem Klein, aslında bir sirkte çalışan,
insanları eğlendiren bir kişiydi.
Ve keşfedilmesi CERN'de çalışan
Amsterdam'lı bir mühendisin sirke
gitmesiyle oldu. Kendisi sirkte yaptığı
olağanüstü matematiksel algoritmalarla
insanları eğlendiriyor. Bununla insanların
eğlendiğini gören mühendis de alıyor
CERN'e getiriyor, ve CERN'in ilk insansı
bilgisayarı oluyor. Şu an kullandığımız
bilgisayarların gelişimini sağlıyor,
katkıda bulunuyor.
Hedy Lamarr. Kendisi bir Hollywood
aktrisi. Ama kendisinin hem Hollywood
aktrisi hem de mucit olması sayesinde
şuan Wi-Fi kullanabiliyoruz.
Wi-Fi teknolojisinin nimetlerinden sonuna
kadar faydalanabiliyoruz.
Hedy, o zaman 1940'lı yıllarda, inanılmaz
derecede bir tanrıça. Birçok filmden
teklif alıyor ve başrol oynuyor.
Ama mutsuz.
Film aralarında yaptığı şey mucitlik.
Çeşitli buluşlar yapmaya çalışıyor ama
hâlâ mutsuz. Çünkü bir amaç, bir değer
yaratmak istiyor.
Bir sorunu çözmek istiyor Hedy.
Yaptığı şey de, Amerika savaşa giderken,
atlamalı frekans sistemini bularak şimdiki
Wi-Fi teknolojisinin üretilmesini sağlıyor
Ve Mirai Nagasu. Olimpiyatları takip eden
var mı? geçen haftadan örnek aldığım
bir rol model, şuan 2018 olimpiyatlarına
damgasını vurdu, Triple Axel atlayışıyla.
Geçen olimpiyatlar, Sochi Olimpiyatları
2014'te yapılmıştı. Mirai çok çalışmasına
rağmen buraya seçilememişti. Ve arkadaşı
ile kendini hamburgercide bulmuşlar.
Şimdi hamburgercide sabaha kadar
düşünmüşler, biz neden seçilemedik?
Hem hamburger yiyorlar hem de bir taraftan
düşünüyorlar nasıl bu şansı kaçırdık diye.
4 yıl sonra ise Mirai arkadaşı ile
birlikte katılıyor ve inanılmaz, ilk defa
bir Amerikalı sporcunun yaptığı Triple
Axel atlayışını yapıyor ve adını tarihe
altın harflerle yazdırıyor.
Aslında, annesi babası Japon, kendisi
Amerika'da doğmuş, annesi ve babasının
kendisi için çizdiği kariyer bir golf
ustası olmasıydı. Golfçü olmasıydı.
Onu her haftasonu golfe götürüyorlarmış.
Bir haftasonu yağmur yağıyor ve golfe
gidemiyorlar, buz patenine götürüyorlar
çocuklarını. Ve Mirai kesinlikle ve
kesinlikle, kendinden emin olarak buz
patenine devam etmek istiyorum diyor ve
devam ediyor. Şimdi 24 yaşında, hem
uluslararası ilişkiler okumuş hem de buz
pateninde inanılmaz bir kariyere sahip.
Şimdi, "Japon" dedik. Japon felsefesini
araştıranlarınız ya da okuyanlarınız varsa
çok derine inmeden, bence hayatımızın
en önemli noktalarından bir tanesine
değinmek istiyorum: Kırılmak. Belki her
gün, belki her hafta, uzun süre
yaşadığımız olaylar. İnsanlar kırılır, acı
çeker, hata yaparlar ama bundan utanmak
çekinmek yerine bu deformasyonu göstermeli
ve en kaliteli şekilde göstermeliyiz.
Kingtsugi bir Japon tekrar tamir etme
sanatı. Diyor ki eğer bu anılara sahip,
bu kırılan anılar... Acı çeken insanlar
çok değerli anılara sahip. Neden bunları
saklasınlar ki? Bunları göstersinler.
Ama tekrar altın suyuyla, altınla tamir
ettiklerinde daha değerli bir forma
kavuşturabilirler. Lütfen derin
felsefesini okuyun, araştırın.
Şimdiden Türkiye'de de Kingtsugi
seminerleri veriliyor. Bunlara da
katılırsanız farklı bir deneyim
elde etmiş olacaksınız.
Ve benim sonum köyüm nasıl bu köyde...
Tekrardan yeniden başlıyorum.
Sonun başlangıcı olan yerlerden birisi.
Çünkü üniversitede işletme fakültesinden
mezun oldum. Mezun olduktan sonra 10 yıl
boyunca 30'a yakın ülkede hem eğitim aldım
çalıştım, araştırdım. Amerika'dan Asya'ya
çok farklı alanlarda eğitimlerimi gerçekleştirdim.
gerçekleştirdim ama biliyordum ki ne
yapacaksam yapacağım,sanat ve teknolojiyi
entegre eden işler yapacağım.
Sonra döndüm, kendimi o köyde buldum.
Ayvalık'ta terkedilmiş bir köyü, bilim ve
sanat köyü yapma idealiyle
yanıp tutuşmuyordum, böyle bir şey yoktu.
Benim tek bir amacım vardı. Çocukluğumun
geçtiği Ayvalık'ta kültür turizmi yok
olmak üzereydi. Her gün çekirdek
çitleyicilerle, Ayvalık tostu yemeye
gelenlerle karşılaşıyordum.
orada bir değişim ve dönüşüme
ihtiyaç vardı.
Sanatçılar ve girişmcilerin bir arada
çalışacağı bir mekân tasarlamaya
çalışırken bir baktım ki kendimi köyde
buldum. Bu terkedilmiş köy, yaklaşık 555
yıl önce yeniçeriler tarafından kurulmuş.
Daha sonra Rumlar, daha sonrasında da
Boşnak halkı gelmiş ama yüz yıldan beri
terkedilmiş bir köydü.
Ne yaptık köyümüze? Birbirinden farklı
tasarımcıları, sanatçıları, girişimcileri
ve bilim insanlarını çağırdık. Bir ortak
yaşama ve paylaşma alanı kurmaya
çalışıyoruz. Bu sene dördüncü yılımızdayız
Temmuz ayında da uluslararası bir
işbirliğine, etkinliğe ev sahipliği
yapacağız. Eğer Temmuz ayında fırsatınız
olursa sizi köyümüze mutlaka bekliyoruz.
Köyümüzün meydanında eski bir kıraathaneyi
aldık, içine sanatı ekledik,"art"ı ekledik
Ve bir dijital inkübasyon merkezi hâline
getirdik. Buradaki "Kıraarthane"nin amacı
ise köylü çocuklarımıza, imkanı olmayan
çocuklarımıza rol model söyleşileri yapmak
oyun tasarımı eğitimleri vermek ve onların
farklı bir vizyon elde etmelerini sağlamak
Biraz karanlık çıkmış ama burada köy
çocuklarımızın yaklaşık 9-11 yaşında
aldığı eğitimlerden sonraki
mutlu bir anımız.
Ve biz köyde çalışırken hem köy çocukları
hem de kendimiz için çalışıyoruz çünkü
Hedy Lamarr'ın, Louis Daguerre'in
yüzyıllar önce yaptıkları ve bugün için
kullandığımız Wi-Fi, fotoğraf makinesi,
bilgisayarlar sayesinde biz şuan köyde
oyun geliştirebiliyoruz. Oyun tasarlaya-
biliyoruz ve bunu dünyaya sunabiliyoruz.
İlk oyunumuzu köyde gerçekleştirdik,
"Recontact: Istanbul"du adı.
İlk defa video sanatıyla mobil oyunu
entegre ettik, ve dünya çapında bir oyun
oldu. İkinci oyunumuz ise
"Recontact: Istanbul, Eyes of Sky"
Dünyanın ilk sinematografik mobil oyunu.
Mobil oyuncular var mı aramızda.
Kimler mobil oyun oynuyor? Hocalarınız
önde oturuyor herkes el kaldırabilir.
Şimdi oyunu isterseniz ücretsiz bir
şekilde platformlardan indirebilirsiniz.
İlk oyunla ikinci oyun arasındaki
gelişmeyi ve farklılığı da göreceksiniz.
Oyun endüstrisi etki alanı bakımından
en güçlü ve en zengin alanlardan biri.
Ama şimdiye kadar böyle ciddi bir şekilde
bakılmamıştı. Yani ailemize gidip ben
bir oyun yapımcısıyım dediğinde kimse
ciddiye almazdı. Ki ben öyle bir şey
dememiştim, o yol suyunu akıp bulmuştu.
Şimdi ben sadece şunu dedim:
Ben yaratıcı endüstrilerde çalışacağım.
Sanat ve teknolojiyle entegre işler
yapacağım. Kardeşim Eray Dinç de film
yönetmeniydi. Film yönetmenliğindeki
entelektüel bilgisini aldı oyun
endüstrisine entegre etti.
Ve şu an 3 kişiyle başladığımız
yolculuğumuza 30 kişiyle devam ediyoruz.
Ve 30 kişinin her biri de birbirinden
farklı disiplinlerden geliyor.
Biri işletme okumuş, biri politika
okumuş, biri kimyacı... farklı sektörler.
Ama hepsi o artı değerleri, öğrendiklerini
bu sektörde birleştiriyor.
Yani bir şeyi okuduğunuzda, şuan bir
meslek seçmek zoundasınız evet, ama bu
mesleği hiçbir zaman negatif yönde
düşünmeyin. Belki seçtiğiniz ve girdiğiniz
zaman o meslekten mutlu olmayabilirsiniz
ama bunun her zaman geri dönüşü olacak.
Daha doğrusu oradaki artı değeri
alacaksınız ve farklı bir sektör
yaratabileceksiniz. 15 sene sonra diyorum
arkadaşlar. Hiçbir şey belli olmayacak,
yeni meslekler çıkacak ve siz orada değer
yaratmaya başlayacaksınız. Belki de
girişimci olacaksınız. Çünkü şuan
istediğiniz mesleğin bölümü bile
olmayabilir. Belki o mesleği siz
kuracaksınız. O bölümü siz kuracaksınız.
O yüzden hiç karadeliğin içinde kaybolmaya
gerek yok.
Fikret Kuşkan'ın başrolünde olduğu,
Ahmet Ümit'in senaryo danışmanlığını
yaptığı oyunumuzu piyasaya çıkarmadan önce
de tabi girişimci olarak birçok kişiyle
görüşüyorsunuz ve işbirliği yapmak
istiyorsunuz. Benden sonraki
konuşmacılardan biri Sevil Atasoy. Sevil
Atasoy'a da biz gittik, ama Sevil Atasoy
bize hiç geri dönmedi mesela. Böyle şeyler
de oluyor. Belki siz projenizi iyi
anlatamayabilirsiniz ya da karşı
taraftakinin heyecanı oyun endüstrisine
karşı o kadar yüksek olmayabilir.
Ama yapacağınız işte, o heyecanı duyacak
ve katma değer yaratacak insanlarla bir
arada olacağınız zaman, o ekibi
kurabileceğiniz zaman dünya çapında işler
yapmamanız için hiçbir neden yok.
Evet ve bu oyun endüstrisine girdikten
sonra baktım ki hiç kadın yok.
Yani %20 kadın %80 erkek.
Erkek hegomanyasında geçen bir endüstri.
"Nasıl bir cinsiyet ayrımı olabilir ki bir
meslekler grubunda?" dedik ve
"Women In Games Türkiye"yi kurduk
Amacımız kadınlarımızı oyun endüstrisiyle
ilgili yetiştirmek, eğitimler vermek.
Yer alanlarla yer almak isteyenleri
bir araya getirmek ekipte de bilgisayar
mühendisimiz var, politika uzmanımız var
politika ve tıp okumuş arkadaşımız var,
Birbirinden değerli arkadaşlarımız var.
Şimdi yoğurt en temel yiyeceklerden bir
tanesi. Herkesin yoğurt yiyişi farklı.
Ama elinizdeki bir kaşıkla da dünyaya
yetecek kadar yoğurt yapabilirsiniz.
Sabırla ve azimle. Çobani markasını
duydunuz mu arkadaşlar?
Muhteşem bir girişimcilik örneği.
Tunceli'den çıkan bir arkadaş Amerika'ya
gidiyor. Eski bir yoğurt fabrikasını
alıyor ve şu an dünyaya Çobani
markasıyla yoğurtları satabiliyor.
Biz henüz evrimleşen yaratıklarız
arkadaşlar. Daha çok gelişeceğiz.
Sadece mayanız temiz olsun, niyetiniz iyi
olsun, sizin yapamayacağınız hiçbir iş yok
Bir girişmci olarak önemli olan harika bir
fikir çıkarmanız değil, harika bir soruna
odaklanmanız. Ne kadar sorun çözerseniz,
ne kadar sorun çözme kası geliştirirseniz
vücudunuzdaki kaslar önemli değil, bu
içinizdeki sorun çözebilme kası önemli.
Eğer bunu geliştirirseniz çok farklı
işlerde farklı deneyimler insanlara
sunabilirisiniz. Ve deneyim kazanmadan o
işe olan tutkunuzu ölçemezsiniz.
Size anlatılabilir aileniz tarafından.
doktorluk çok güzel, mühendislik çok güzel
diye anlatılabilir. Ama siz orada
hissetmeden, deneyim kazanamadan
maalesef ama maalesef mutlu olacağınız
sektörü seçemezsiniz. O yüzden niyetiniz
iyi olsun, yapamayacağınız iş yoktur
arkadaşlar.
Ve şu sözümle bitirmek istiyorum.
Doğdum sevindiler,
Öldüm üzüldüler;
Ama yaşadığımı farketmediler.
Arkadaşlar sizler yaşadığınızı farkettirin
Kendi değerinizin önce farkında olun.
Çok teşekkür ediyorum.